Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in a learning disability service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good
你好，我是Max，在西约克郡的一家学习障碍服务机构担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢而坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个最终目标，我想看看市面上有什么书能对此有所帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并决定买下它，这对我的旅程大有裨益。我觉得玛丽安的书非常有启发性，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你具备良好的
interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Psychology loves talking about inclusion. That is, of course, until a blind person arrives at interview or on placement with a guide dog in tow and they're ready to work or ready to try out for the role. And then suddenly everyone realizes just how inaccessible our systems really are. In this episode, I'm chatting with Sky about what it actually takes to train as a psychologist, when the world wasn't necessarily designed with you in mind.
人际交往能力，比如同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学世界的人，它让我渴望有一天能在这个领域工作。心理学界热衷于谈论包容性。当然，这仅限于当一个盲人带着导盲犬出现在面试或实习现场，准备工作或尝试应聘时。然后，大家突然意识到我们的系统实际上是多么缺乏包容性。在这一集中，我将与Sky聊聊，当世界并非为你而设计时，成为一名心理学家到底需要付出什么。
We hope you find it really helpful. If you do, please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am joined here by Sky Hewitt. Welcome along, Sky. Hi, thank you for having me. Thank you for your, you know, your willingness to talk with us so openly. And we were talking just before we started about the fact that you are now a first-year trainee clinical psychologist.
我们希望你觉得这很有帮助。如果确实如此，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，今天和我在一起的是Sky Hewitt。欢迎你，Sky。你好，谢谢你邀请我。感谢你如此坦诚地与我们交谈。我们在开始录制前聊到，你现在是一名一年级的临床心理学实习生。
And moreover than that, you know, what's even more impressive because that is an achievement in itself is that you're also registered blind and you have a guide dog called Derek. Could you tell us a little bit about your journey to being a trainee if that's OK, Sky? Yeah, absolutely. So I suppose I started working out that I wanted to study psychology or become a psychologist whilst I was doing my A levels as a lot of us sort of do. And I ended up doing an integrated master's degree. So sort of an undergraduate four year master's degree in psychology. And I really enjoyed that. And then I decided to apply for a post. postgraduate master's degree in clinical neuroscience because I really enjoyed my neuroscience modules and I thought let's go and study something a bit different, especially because I found out about a really amazing opportunity through the Snowden Trust who offer scholarships for disabled students and grants and different things. So I sort of took my shot at that and was lucky enough to get one. So I did that. And then I became an AP.
不仅如此，更令人印象深刻的是——因为这本身就是一项成就——你还是一名注册盲人，并且有一只名叫Derek的导盲犬。Sky，如果可以的话，你能跟我们分享一下你成为实习生的历程吗？好的，没问题。我想我是在读A-level课程时开始意识到我想学习心理学或成为一名心理学家，就像我们很多人那样。我最终攻读了一个综合硕士学位，也就是四年的心理学本硕连读。我非常喜欢这个过程。后来，我决定申请临床神经科学的研究生硕士学位，因为我非常喜欢神经科学模块，我想去学点不同的东西，特别是因为我通过斯诺登信托基金（Snowden Trust）发现了一个非常棒的机会，他们为残疾学生提供奖学金、助学金等。所以我尝试了一下，很幸运地获得了资助。于是我完成了学业，然后成为了一名助理心理学家（AP）。
for a year and applied for the Declin, got a few interviews, got a couple of offers and sort of here I am and so it's been a whirlwind of different things and changes and yeah. Thank you so much and yeah like I said we did have a chat before we hit record as well and I feel like you might have a touch of imposter syndrome about you Sky but yeah that's that's healthy I would say but it doesn't mean that you're not ready to be doing what you're doing. You know, you clearly have learned your trade and evidence that you are qualified to be where you are at. But also, I think, you know, when you've had adverse experiences, it kind of helps you develop that bit quicker than people who often don't. And when you're having to be, you know, advocating for yourself
做了一年，申请了临床心理学博士课程（DClin），参加了几次面试，拿到了一些录取通知，然后就到了这里。这真是一段充满变化和不同经历的旋风之旅。非常感谢，正如我之前所说，我们在录音前聊过，我觉得你可能有一点冒名顶替综合症，Sky，但这很正常，但这并不意味着你没有准备好做你正在做的事情。你知道，你显然已经掌握了你的专业技能，并证明了你有资格处于现在的位置。而且，我认为当你经历过逆境时，它会帮助你比那些没有经历过的人更快地成长。当你不得不
constantly and relentlessly, I think it drags you up a bit quicker. Do you agree with you? I do. I think especially when I do, I don't know, when I compare myself to my peers who are my age or my colleagues who are a little bit older than me, you know, even as an AP and my colleagues who were maybe in their 30s and we'd talk about what they were doing at my age versus what I'm doing. And yeah, I think maybe I have just had to grow up quite quick and get used to communicating in different ways quite quickly. And yeah, so I'd agree with. that for sure and is it okay for me to say how old you are sky yeah yeah I'm 24 perfect so you will be qualified long before you're 30 so yeah like you
不断且不懈地为自己辩护时，我认为这会让你成长得更快。你同意吗？我同意。我认为特别是当我把自己和同龄人，或者比我大一点的同事相比时，即使是在我做助理心理学家时，那些可能30多岁的同事会谈论他们在我的年纪在做什么，而我在做什么。是的，我想我可能确实不得不快速成长，并迅速习惯用不同的方式进行沟通。所以，我肯定同意这一点。我可以问一下你的年龄吗，Sky？可以，我24岁。太棒了，那你30岁之前就能获得执业资格了。所以，做得好，我希望你真的能享受这段培训时光。这是一段真正的转型期，你会从不同的人身上学习，有些人你会喜欢他们的工作方式，有些人则不会，你只需要保留你喜欢的部分。所以我真的希望你能享受培训。如果可以的话，你能告诉我们你的视力受损程度吗？好的，正如我们所说，我是注册盲人，但这并不意味着我完全看不见，我仍然有一点视力可以使用。我一直都是注册盲人。我天生患有青光眼，成长过程中做过很多次手术，随后眼睛也出现了很多问题。
know well done to you and I hope that you really enjoy training it's a real time of transformation and you get to learn from people some of whom you will like their approach some of whom you won't and you just get to keep the bits that you do like so I do hope that you enjoy training Could you tell us if it's okay a little bit about your, about the level of your visual impairment? Yeah, so as we sort of said, I'm registered blind, but that means I still have a little bit of vision that I can use. So I've always been registered blind. I was born with glaucoma and have had lots of different surgeries and subsequent sort of problems with my eyes growing up.
我一直有一点视力，但视力在慢慢恶化。现在我仍然可以阅读一些非常大的文字，看到一些东西，也能辨认出人是谁。但是的，我是注册盲人。谢谢。我非常希望这一集能成为那些有视力障碍的人的灵感来源，让他们想到：“哦，我以前没意识到心理学对我来说可能是一个选择。”或者也许有人告诉过他们：“这不是你的选择。”因此他们对此感到灰心。所以也许我们能在他们教育的早期阶段就接触到他们，让他们觉得：“哦，太好了。”
I've always had a bit of vision that's slowly gotten worse. And now I can still sort of read some very large text and see a few things and people to make out who people are here and there. But yeah, registered blind. Thank you. And yeah, I would love this episode to be used as inspiration for people that might have their own visual impairments to think, oh, I didn't realize psychology was maybe an option for me. Or maybe someone's told them, this isn't an option for you. And so they've been discouraged by that. So maybe we can get them early enough in their education that they're like, oh, nice.
好吧，让我去探索一下。或者我们可以鼓励人们进行再培训，或者思考他们可能需要采取哪些步骤。同时，我们也真的希望这一集能被那些没有视力障碍的人听到，让他们思考一下，比如，什么样的语言可能是合适的或不合适的，什么样的表达方式是首选或非首选的，并了解视力障碍者的经历，从而为他们的实践提供参考，激发他们的好奇心，甚至想到一些他们以前可能不知道的想法。甚至在录音之前，我们就聊到了一些事情，你说：“哦，我不太喜欢那样。”所以我们会涵盖其中的一些内容，但这一集
Okay, let me explore. Or maybe we can encourage people to kind of retrain or think about what steps they might need to do. But also, we really want this episode to be used by people who do not have visual impairments to think about, I don't know, language that might be okay or not okay, that might be preferred or not preferred. or not preferred, and for learning about the experience of people with visual impairments to inform their practice, make them curious, and maybe even think of some ideas that they might not know already. And even before we hit record, we spoke about a couple of things and you were like, oh, I don't really love about that. So we will cover some of that, but this is
计划成为一个多用途的节目。但我们确实想赋予听众力量，无论出于什么原因，我们都想赋予听众力量。这至少是我们的计划。如果可以的话，你能告诉我们一点吗？你不需要点名任何人。你是否经历过任何污名化，或者因为你想成为一名合格的临床心理学家而受到过劝阻？是的，情况比较复杂。我觉得在视力障碍领域，有很多咨询师和治疗师，但我觉得当涉及到专门追求临床心理学时，突然之间就有了更多的污名和障碍。对我来说，这确实是从本科开始的，人们真的不知道我是否能做到，或者这是否可能，或者我有这些抱负是否合理。但更具体地说，我有过一次非常独特的经历，
going to be a kind of a multi-purpose episode is the plan. But yeah, like really empowering is what we want to, we want to empower anyone listening for any reason. That's the plan anyway. Could you tell us a little bit, if it feels okay, you don't need to single anyone out? Have you experienced any stigma or kind of dissuasion for the idea of going on to become a qualified clinical psychologist? Yeah, it's somewhat mixed. I feel like in the visual impairment world, there are a lot of counsellors and a lot of therapists in different ways but I think when it comes to pursuing clinical psychology specifically there's suddenly a bit more stigma and barriers I guess and I think for me it did start at undergrad specifically and just people not really knowing if I could do it or if it would be possible. if it was reasonable for me to have those aspirations. But then more specifically, I have had a very distinct experience
在面试助理心理学家职位时，其中一次面试，我不知道，我认为那是严重的意识缺乏，但他们几乎对我直说，如果他们知道我是盲人，他们就不会邀请我面试。他们认为我因为各种原因无法胜任这份工作，比如他们使用了很多纸质表格，或者他们不理解为什么我的导盲犬Derek在场。
when interviewing for AP positions, assistant psychologist positions, where one of my interviews, I just don't, I think it was a significant lack of awareness, but they pretty much said to me, if they knew that I was blind, they wouldn't have invited me to interview. They didn't think I could do the job because of different things. like they used a lot of paper forms or they didn't understand why Derek, my guide dog, was
所以那是一次非常令人震惊的经历。幸运的是，我参加了另一次助理心理学家的面试，过程非常顺利，我最终和他们一起工作，那是一个绝对出色的团队。所以经历截然不同。但是的，我没想到会发生这种事，但它确实发生了。我很遗憾听到这些，但他们那样对你说不是违法的吗？是的，是的。我想在当时，我仍然处于那种模式中，你知道，你来到这个面试小组，你试图给人留下深刻印象，你试图得到一份工作，我仍然非常努力地向他们证明：“嗯，你知道，我们可以做到这一点，我们可以做到这一点，我可以胜任这份工作。”直到我离开并思考这件事时，
there. So that was quite a jarring experience. Fortunately, I had another assistant psychologist interview that went very well and I ended up working with them and it was an absolutely incredible team. So very different experiences. But yeah, I didn't expect it, but it definitely happened and yeah I'm sorry to hear that but isn't it isn't it illegal for for them to say that to you yes yes I think in the moment I was still in that mode of you know you're coming to this panel interview you're trying to impress you're trying to get a job and I and I was still very much trying to almost prove to them well you know we can do this we can do this and I can do the job and it wasn't until I came away and thought about it
我才突然反思那次经历是多么的不妥。有趣的是，我确实收到了那个职位的录用通知，但我拒绝了，接受了另一个。所以，这是一次有趣的经历，但你是对的，这样做是违法的。是的，我认为人们让你感觉如何是非常重要的。我曾经处于那种被录用但我不喜欢整个过程的情况，
where I then suddenly was reflecting on how not okay that experience was. Interestingly, I did get offered that position but then I turned it down and accepted the other one. So yeah, it was an interesting experience, but you're right it is illegal to do that. Yeah, I think there's very much something about the way people make you feel I've been in a position where I've been offered jobs and hadn't liked the process.
然后决定拒绝。我认为这确实是在践行你自己的价值观，知道你是值得的，你应该受到尊严和尊重。我确实认识另一位合格的心理学家，一位盲人健康心理学家，他有一只导盲犬。所以我通过他了解了一些关于他的狗可以去哪里，不能去哪里。
and then decided to say no. And I think that's, you know, that's really living up to your own values and knowing that you're worthwhile and you should be treated with dignity and respect. I do know of another qualified psych, a health psychologist who is blind and has a going dog. And so I've learned a little bit through him about where his dog can go and where his dog can't go.
那么，Sky，你能为我们的听众普及一下我可能指的是什么吗？好的。这实际上与我的助理心理学家职位也非常相关，因为我当时在一个临床健康心理学团队，我们经常要去医院工作。所以，虽然导盲犬在法律上几乎可以进入任何地方，但也有一些例外。比如在有严格感染控制要求的环境中。
So could you eliminate our audience about what I might mean there, Sky? Yeah. So this is actually quite relevant for me as well with my AP position because I was in a clinical health psychology team, which often we were then going and working in the hospital. So, yeah, wild guide dogs legally have access to pretty much everywhere. There are a few exceptions. So that would be places where there are a strict sort of infection control sorts of settings.
我想到的是重症监护室（ICU），因为我作为助理心理学家的工作之一是在一个ICU心理学研究项目上。所以医院里确实有一些区域，而在心理学界之外，动物园之类的地方可以拒绝服务犬，因为他们必须考虑自己动物的福利。但总的来说，导盲犬在法律上应该被允许进入几乎所有地方，除了少数例外。是的，我想那位心理学家提到的一个论点是，实际上在Airbnb、酒店、火车和出租车上，在这些情况下你是不被允许拒绝的，对吗，Sky？没错，对于所有这些例子，比如Airbnb和出租车，如果人们确实有严重的过敏症，他们可以走一些程序。但他们不能仅仅说：“我有过敏症，你不能带你的导盲犬。”他们必须有正式的文件证明这一点。所以不幸的是，这非常普遍。我几乎在所有地方都遇到过拒绝进入的情况。在不同类型的场所，Airbnb、出租车、商店、餐馆。而且，每一次都令人失望。
I'm thinking ICU because part of my work as an AP was on an ICU psychology research project. So there are certain areas in hospitals and outside of the psychology world, zoos and things can decline service dogs because they have to think about their own animal welfare. But yeah, on the large scale guide dogs should legally be allowed. pretty much everywhere bar a few exceptions yeah and i think some of the arguments that um that the psychologist i'm thinking of is it's actually air bn bs and hotels and and kind of trains and taxes and you're not allowed to to say no in those circumstances is that right sky that's correct there are like for all of those examples um i'm thinking about air bn bs and taxis There are a few procedures that people can go through if they do have a significant allergy.
而且，这需要不断提醒人们法律规定，以及为什么允许服务犬进入如此重要。是的，绝对重要。我们确实需要真正提出这种叙事并加强它。实际上，我认为Derek在治疗上可能是一个真正的优势和资产。我明白他不是治疗犬，他不是受过训练的治疗犬，他是一个……他叫什么名字？他是一个辅助犬，对吧？是的，辅助犬或服务犬，但在那个范畴下，他是我的导盲犬。好的。但你知道，对于我过去合作过的各种客户，房间里有一只狗会
But they can't just say, I have an allergy. You can't bring your guide dog. They have to have formal paperwork and things that say that. So unfortunately, it's very common. I've had access refusals pretty much everywhere. It's in different types of settings. Airbnb, taxis, shops, restaurants. And it's, yeah, it's disappointing every single time.
非常有益。然而，你知道，有时我做过一些恐狗症的工作，根据Derek的品种，这可能感觉没那么有帮助。所以，客户是否会提前知道你有视力障碍，还是他们第一天来的时候就会发现：“哦，这是Derek，这是Sky？”对于个别客户，我最近想到的是，当我预约一些人时，我会给他们预警。我说：“只是想让你知道我有一只服务犬，这可以吗？你对房间里有一只狗有什么想法吗？”我不一定会在电话里直接透露我是盲人，他是一只导盲犬，但我会说我有一只服务犬，然后当我们见面时，我能更多地谈论作为盲人治疗师意味着什么。但历史上，也有一些例子，比如如果我进入医院的团体环境，我可能不会提前告诉他们，但这更多是专业团体环境。但一对一的情况下，我喜欢给人们一点预警，因为你是对的，人们可能
And it's, you know, constantly reminding people. of the law and and you know why it's so important to allow a service still in yeah absolutely it's so important we we kind of raise this narrative really and reinforce it and actually i think derrick could be a real strength and a real asset therapeutically so i understand he's not a therapy dog he's not a trained therapy dog he's a he's a what's he what is his name what's his is an assistant's dog isn't he yeah assistant's dog or service dog but then under that umbrella he's my guide dog so yeah yeah okay um but you know for i think for a variety of clients i've worked with in the past having a dog in the room would have
对狗有各种各样的过往经历，而且Derek是一只大狗，他是德国牧羊犬和金毛寻回犬的混血，所以你真的不知道这会如何影响空间。我的意思是，对于很多人来说，仅仅有狗在场可能非常积极。我知道对我来说，他在工作之外也是一个巨大的破冰者，在社交上也是如此，对很多人来说是一个令人安慰的存在，但你永远不知道人们会对此有何感受。是的，绝对。是的，Derek是破冰者。他听起来确实是一只大狗。
been really beneficial um however you know sometimes i've done some dog phobia at work and you know depending on what breed derrick is that might have felt not that helpful um so yeah like Do clients ever know in advance that you are going to be visually impaired or do they rock up on day one and then it's like, oh, here's Derek, his sky? So individual clients, I'm thinking about recently where I've booked some people in, I do give them the warning. I say, just to let you know I have a service dog, like, is that okay? Do you have any thoughts about that, like about there being a dog in the room? I don't necessarily disclose right away on the phone call that I'm blind and he's a guide dog but I say I have a service dog and then when we meet I'll be able to talk more about what it might mean having a blind therapist but historically there are a few examples maybe if I'm going into a group setting in a hospital where I might not tell them in advance but that's more of like a professional group setting but but yeah one to one I like to give people that bit of warning because you're right people could
我想在我们YouTube的一个缩略图中，至少有一张Derek的照片。所以如果有人想看看Derek和Sky，他们绝对可以。我们可以聊聊我们应该如何称呼视力障碍者吗？就在录音前，我们谈到实际上，你知道，在最近几年，自闭症患者现在喜欢被称为“身份优先”。称呼你为“盲人”、“视力障碍者”或“视觉受损者”可以吗？我知道这可能对你来说很具体，但你能解释一下我们该如何与人进行这种对话，以及你的偏好是什么吗？是的，这非常因人而异。我认为我合作过的不同慈善机构和认识的不同人都有不同的偏好。所以询问你正在交谈的人他们希望如何被称呼真的很重要。对我来说，我想我更喜欢“身份优先”的语言，比如我会说我喜欢把自己描述为“盲人”，或者我经常会说我是“注册盲人”，仅仅是因为人们有一种误解，认为如果我说我是盲人，就意味着我绝对什么都看不见。
have all sorts of previous experiences with dogs and Derek is a big dog he's half German shepherd half golden retriever so yeah you just don't know how that might impact on the space and I mean it could be very positive for a lot of people just having the dog there I know for me he's a massive icebreaker you know outside of work as well just socially and is is a comforting presence for a lot of people, but you just never know how people are going to feel about it. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, Derek the icebreaker. He does sound like a big dog.
有各种各样的养狗经验，而且德里克是一只大狗，它是德国牧羊犬和金毛寻回犬的混血，所以你真的不知道这会对空间产生什么影响。我的意思是，对很多人来说，有只狗在场可能非常积极。我知道对我来说，它是一个巨大的破冰船，你知道，在工作之外的社交场合也是如此，而且对很多人来说，它是一种令人安慰的存在，但你永远不知道人们会对此有何感想。是的，绝对是这样。是的，德里克是破冰船。听起来他确实是一只大狗。
I think in one of our thumbnails on YouTube, I think we've got at least one photo of Derek. So if anyone wants to check Derek out with Sky, they absolutely can. Can we have a little bit of a chat about kind of how we should refer to somebody with a visual impairment? So just before we hit record, we were talking about actually, you know, over the most recent years, autistic people now like to be identity first. Is it okay to call you a blind person or a person with visual impairments or a visually impaired person? Like, I appreciate this might be specific to you, but could you maybe explain how we would have that conversation with somebody and what your preference is? Yeah, so it is very individual. I think the different charities I've worked with and different people I know all have different preferences. So it is really important to ask the person that you're speaking to how they would prefer to be spoken about. For me, I think I prefer identity first language, sort of saying I like to describe myself as a blind person or often I'll say I'm registered blind just because people. have this misconception that if I say I'm blind it means I can see absolutely
我想在我们YouTube的一个缩略图中，至少有一张德里克的照片。所以如果有人想看看德里克和斯凯，他们完全可以。我们能聊聊我们应该如何称呼视障人士吗？就在我们开始录音之前，我们谈到了实际上，你知道，在最近几年，自闭症患者现在喜欢身份优先的称呼。称呼你为盲人、视障人士或视觉受损者可以吗？我想这可能因人而异，但你能解释一下我们该如何与某人进行这种对话，以及你的偏好是什么吗？是的，这确实非常因人而异。我认为我合作过的不同慈善机构和认识的不同人都有不同的偏好。所以询问你正在交谈的人他们更喜欢如何被称呼真的很重要。对我来说，我想我更喜欢身份优先的语言，比如我喜欢把自己描述为盲人，或者我经常会说我是注册盲人，只是因为人们有一种误解，认为如果我说我是盲人，就意味着我什么都看不见
nothing and that's not the case so that I often try and it's hard isn't it I try and balance my language to almost make sure people understand what I mean but also advocating for a broader understanding of what the words mean as well but yeah I I don't have enormous strong feelings either way but I I tend to lean towards identity first language Thank you. So maybe almost like a little bit of an imposter syndrome there about calling yourself blind because you've got some usable vision. But yeah, people's, people's understanding of the term blind is literally that there'd be nothing. And when I was working in the community
并不是那样，所以我也经常尝试，这很难，不是吗？我试图平衡我的语言，几乎确保人们理解我的意思，同时也倡导对这些词汇含义有更广泛的理解。但是的，我在这方面并没有特别强烈的感受，但我倾向于使用身份优先的语言。谢谢。所以，当你因为还有一些可用视力而称自己为盲人时，可能会有一种冒名顶替综合症。但确实，人们对“盲人”这个词的理解字面上就是什么都看不见。当我还在社区工作时
with people with physical disabilities, I very quickly learned that you can have a registration as blind, but actually still be able to even read some text, as you said, that you can. But yeah, you are very much, is it okay to see disadvantaged compared to people with 2020 vision? Is that, is that all right? That's appropriate to say. Yeah, I'd say so. You know, I have a disability. I'm a disabled person. There are various things that I'm disadvantaged by.
与残疾人一起工作时，我很快了解到，即使你注册为盲人，实际上可能仍然能够阅读一些文字，正如你所说的那样。但确实，你非常……与视力正常的人相比，说处于弱势地位可以吗？这样说合适吗？是的，我想可以。你知道，我有残疾。我是一个残疾人。我确实在某些方面处于弱势。
I do think often about like the social model of disability and how it is the environment and the systems that cause most of the problems. You know, I can do a lot of things completely independently and work things out for myself as long as the environment and the systems are set up in a suitable way. So, yeah, whilst my vision puts me at a disadvantage in some ways, I would also say the systems are often more of the problem. Yeah, and that really nicely segues us into what was going to be in the next area for conversation, which is kind of the tools that help you to kind of engage. engage fully with the tasks that you need to do.
我经常思考残疾的社会模式，以及环境和系统是如何导致大多数问题的。你知道，只要环境和系统设置得当，我可以完全独立地做很多事情，并自己解决问题。所以，虽然我的视力在某些方面让我处于劣势，但我也会说系统往往才是更大的问题。是的，这很好地引出了我们下一个讨论领域，也就是那些帮助你充分参与你需要完成的任务的工具。
Could you give us a little bit of an overview of the things that really support you to thrive optimally at work and maybe at home as well? Yeah, I mean, practically I rely on a lot of technology. So a lot of accessibility software, large screens, high contrast, magnification, voice over occasionally when I need to use that. I benefit from a lot of sort of extra time for orientation and mobility for myself, but also for Derek.
你能给我们概述一下那些真正支持你在工作和家庭中实现最佳状态的事物吗？是的，实际上我非常依赖技术。所以很多辅助功能软件、大屏幕、高对比度、放大功能，偶尔需要时还会用到旁白（VoiceOver）。我受益于很多额外的定向和行动时间，不仅是为了我自己，也是为了德里克（导盲犬）。
You know, he has to learn new routes and it can be tricky making sure his training is up to par and he's meeting my needs if I'm not given enough time to do all of that. It's interesting. I'm, I feel like, and I'm sure a lot of disabled people will relate to this, we get very good at problem solving and just working things out and to an extent getting by. And so I think the thing that's most impactful, for me at least, is just having really direct contact with course tutors, supervisors, really open communication because it's very hard to just have cut and dry solutions to things and one thing might work one day and not the next or for one system and not the other. and it's so granular and situation-specific. So having that regular contact just to troubleshoot and discuss and even just think about how you're feeling about all of it because it's also exhausting. I really don't want to understate how time-consuming being disabled is
你知道，他必须学习新的路线，如果我没有足够的时间来完成所有这些，确保他的训练达标并满足我的需求可能会很棘手。这很有趣。我觉得，我相信很多残疾人都会有同感，我们变得非常擅长解决问题，只是想办法应付，在一定程度上凑合着过。所以我认为对我来说最有效的事情，就是与课程导师、主管保持非常直接的联系，进行非常开放的沟通，因为很难有简单直接的解决方案，有时候一种方法今天有效，明天就无效，或者对一个系统有效，对另一个系统却无效。这非常细致且因情况而异。所以保持定期的联系来解决问题、讨论，甚至只是思考你对这一切的感受，因为这也让人精疲力竭。我真的不想低估残疾是多么耗时
and the administrative burden, the way it takes so much energy and thinking just to sort of do everything that everyone else is doing. So yeah. Thanks, Sky. And like if, you know, if you were my trainee, I would have quite a steep learning curve to be able to think about how to teach you
以及行政负担，那种为了做每个人都在做的事情而需要消耗如此多精力和思考的方式。所以是的。谢谢，斯凯。如果，你知道，如果你是我的学员，我需要经历一个相当陡峭的学习曲线，才能思考如何教你
to do the things that I would see as kind of quite, the processes that I would want you to have an understanding of. Like, could we almost do like a little bit of a, this is how we would get around that or we would do this differently? So, for example, if you were joining me for an initial assessment, And I would use my remarkable tablet and I would usually, or paper, you know, in old school days, I would usually sort of draw a family tree to get an understanding systemically of that person and their relationships. And I would usually jot down sort of histories about, you know, presenting problems or significant bits and pieces of their life.
去做那些我认为相当……我希望你理解的流程。比如，我们是否可以稍微做一点……这是我们如何绕过那个问题，或者我们会以不同的方式做这件事？例如，如果你和我一起进行初步评估，我会使用我的Remarkable平板电脑，或者在老派的日子里，我会使用纸张，我通常会画一个家谱，从系统层面了解那个人及其关系。我通常会记下关于他们提出的问题或生活中重要片段的历史。
And maybe, you know, some physical health bits and their previous history with kind of mental health services and whether. there were any medication. I do not feel I would be able to accurately hold all of that in my mind for an initial assessment, especially if I then needed to go away and write a report. So could you guide us through how you would help me as a potential supervisor to help you thrive optimally in that sort of setting? Yeah. So, I mean, these are conversations I've been having a lot recently as well anyway and for me it's because I am able to handwrite something sort of on my iPad. I know you mentioned the remarkable tablet, but I'm able to do some of that, you know, handwrite some notes and make sure it's just very big and high contrast and then I can have
也许，你知道，一些身体健康方面的信息，以及他们之前与心理健康服务的接触史，还有是否服用过任何药物。我觉得我无法准确地在脑海中记住所有这些信息来进行初步评估，特别是如果我之后还需要去写报告的话。那么，作为潜在的主管，你能指导我如何帮助你在这类环境中实现最佳状态吗？是的，我的意思是，这些也是我最近经常进行的对话。对我来说，因为我能够在iPad上手写一些东西。我知道你提到了Remarkable平板电脑，但我能够做一些那样的手写笔记，并确保它们非常大且对比度高，然后我可以
a closer look later and type things up or the flip of that I could be sort of touch typing and then review that later. I do also. it whilst yes it is hard to remember I would say a lot of blind people do have incredibly good memories and I do know some people mostly will rely on their memory in sessions that is not me yet I might get there at some point but obviously I'm holding a lot in mind about how to structure assessments and formulations and different things so for me it's a lot of still handwriting notes just in an inaccessible way to me and yeah i imagine it's going to change a lot as i go through training as well but that's the current plan yeah and actually when i was a first year trainee my first placement my placement supervisor encouraged me to to record so audio record all sessions so that we could then listen back to them in supervision but um that is a whole other conversation of cringe but um i guess that might be something that would help you to then listen back to type your reports for example
稍后再仔细查看并打字整理，或者反过来，我可以进行盲打，然后再回顾。我也确实……虽然记住这些确实很难，但我会说很多盲人有令人难以置信的好记性，我知道有些人主要在会议中依赖记忆，但我还不行，我可能在某个时候能做到，但显然我脑子里记着很多关于如何构建评估、构思和不同事情的内容，所以对我来说，仍然有很多手写笔记，只是以一种对我来说无法访问的方式。是的，我想随着我完成培训，情况会有很大变化，但这是目前的计划。是的，实际上当我是一年级学员时，我的第一个实习主管鼓励我录音，录下所有会议，这样我们就可以在督导时回听，但是……那是关于尴尬的另一个话题了，但我猜这可能对你有帮助，比如回听来写报告。
Is that something that you've explored in the past? Yeah, so it definitely will be the plan to record as many sessions as I can. I mean, that's recommended to all of the cohort just for the course requirements and professional development and things. But for me especially, that will be the plan to hopefully record as many as many as I can. Great. And do you read Braille? I can. I don't, just because I'm a very slow. braille reader but yes I can okay and is that taught you know often to people with sight impairments or is it hit and missed does it depend on what kind of school
这是你过去探索过的事情吗？是的，绝对计划录下我能录下的尽可能多的会议。我的意思是，这对所有学员来说都是课程要求和专业发展的建议。但对我来说尤其如此，计划是希望能录下尽可能多的内容。太好了。你会读盲文吗？我会。我只是不怎么用，因为我是一个非常慢的盲文阅读者，但我确实会。好的，这是教给视力受损人士的吗？还是说这取决于你上了什么样的学校？
you went to for example it I I would like to think that any severely visually impaired children are being taught Braille and touch typing that was my experience as much as I didn't enjoy it when I was was little. I think it felt really unnecessary when I was younger, but my understanding is it is or should be offered to every severely visually impaired child, yeah, in school. Okay, but for whatever reason, it's just never really, it's never really resonated with you or you've kind of find other ways around it or because you've got some sight, maybe you haven't had the pressure to really, you know, become very speedy with that. Yeah.
例如，我希望任何视力严重受损的儿童都能被教导盲文和盲打，这就是我的经历，尽管我小时候并不喜欢它。我觉得我小时候觉得这真的很没必要，但我的理解是，它确实应该或被提供给学校里每一个视力严重受损的儿童。好的，但无论出于什么原因，它从未真正引起你的共鸣，或者你找到了其他方法，或者因为你还有一些视力，也许你没有压力去真正变得非常熟练？是的。
I think it's always been because I had enough sight to not have to rely on those things. I never felt as motivated to learn and get really good at it. And then a big discussion about Braille at the moment is how technology is so advanced that do we even need Braille? The argument is we do and Braille allows especially completely blind children to learn a lot more about literacy and things. So I know a lot of people don't learn Braille at all because technology is so advanced now as well. Yeah, thank you. And speaking about technology, I'm aware that the meta AI glasses can
我想一直是因为我有足够的视力，不需要依赖那些东西。我从未感到有动力去学习并变得非常擅长它。目前关于盲文的一个大讨论是，技术如此先进，我们还需要盲文吗？争论的焦点是我们确实需要，盲文允许特别是完全失明的儿童学习更多关于识字和事物的内容。所以我知道很多人根本不学盲文，因为现在的技术也太先进了。是的，谢谢。说到技术，我知道Meta AI眼镜可以
potentially revolutionise kind of what it is like to be someone with a visual impairment or registered blind, because as I understand it, when you wear a pair of them, you can ask it to tell you what it's looking at or it will just read kind of information on screen for you when you look at it. At the moment, I think you couldn't walk down the street and it wouldn't automatically say there's a black dog to your left watch out there's a red brick wall straight in front of you but if you said if there is anything to my left is there anything straight in front of me it would tell you but you can see that over time it will be refined so that it can kind of give you more a running narrative um is there any other technology like do you use the be my eyes app
潜在地彻底改变视力受损或注册盲人的生活，因为据我所知，当你戴上一副眼镜时，你可以要求它告诉你它正在看什么，或者当你看着屏幕时，它会为你阅读屏幕上的信息。目前，我认为你不能走在街上，它不会自动说“你左边有一只黑狗，小心前面有一堵红砖墙”，但如果你说“我左边有什么吗？我正前方有什么吗？”，它会告诉你，但你可以看到随着时间的推移，它会得到改进，从而能为你提供更多的实时叙述。还有其他技术吗？比如你使用Be My Eyes应用程序吗？
or are there any other kind of tech things that we could be be mindful of I do use my phone a lot and sort of the built-in features, even just the camera, you know, being able to take pictures of things, zoom into things, read menus and signs by using the camera. I do use AI quite a lot to speed up different things that I do just because they can take a bit longer or take a bit of extra eye strain. So AI is really helpful. I did also used to have a Braille smartwatch, which was an incredibly interesting piece of tech that I think is currently discontinued, but they will be revamping it hopefully in the future because I would be keen to get a new one. And that was really useful because I could very subtly check the time. And it's one of those things, especially when I think about structuring therapy sessions and
或者还有其他我们可以注意的技术吗？我确实经常使用手机和内置功能，甚至只是相机，你知道，能够拍摄东西、放大东西、通过相机阅读菜单和标志。我确实经常使用人工智能来加速我做的不同事情，只是因为它们可能需要更长时间或导致额外的眼睛疲劳。所以人工智能非常有帮助。我过去也曾拥有一块盲文智能手表，那是一件令人难以置信的有趣技术，我认为目前已经停产了，但希望未来他们会对其进行改进，因为我很想买一块新的。那真的很有用，因为我可以非常隐蔽地查看时间。这是其中之一，特别是当我考虑构建治疗会议和
keeping to time how I can subtly check the time without it being really obvious and that was really great because it did connect to my phone and it would pop up in braille and it would also like read me my text messages and things like that with the braille so I could just silently read those rather than having anything talking to me or you know an enormous clock that I'm having to bring right to my face so yeah there are there are some really interesting pieces of tech in the sort of visual impairment disability space, I think the meta glasses are a really nice example of where that technology is becoming more universal to everybody and there's like a universal piece of tech that also really benefits disabled people. But there is a whole other world of technology that
保持时间时，我如何能在不明显的情况下隐蔽地查看时间，这真的很棒，因为它连接到我的手机，它会以盲文形式弹出，它还会像阅读短信那样为我朗读，所以我可以静静地阅读那些内容，而不是让任何东西对我说话，或者你知道，我必须把一个巨大的时钟带到我脸上。所以是的，在视力障碍残疾领域有一些非常有趣的技术，我认为Meta眼镜是一个很好的例子，说明这种技术正变得对每个人都更加通用，并且有一种通用的技术也真正造福了残疾人。但还有整个另一个技术世界，
just people don't really know about just because it's generally geared towards a specific group of people. I have to say I don't think I'd ever considered how some someone with visual impairment knows the time. And I'm sorry that I hadn't considered that. I think some of the people I worked with in the past wore a watch. But yeah, would perhaps bring it right to their faces. But the idea of a braille watch for somebody that wants to be discreet or, yeah, because you're thinking, how long have we got left of this session and you have to do that?
人们并不真正了解，因为它通常针对特定群体。我必须说，我从来没有考虑过视力受损的人是如何知道时间的。我很抱歉我没有考虑到这一点。我想我过去共事过的一些人戴着手表。但是的，也许会把它直接带到他们脸上。但对于想要谨慎行事的人来说，盲文手表的想法，或者，是的，因为你在想，这次会议我们还剩多少时间，你必须这样做？
Or if you're thinking, you know, you're going on a bit, my friend. And we haven't really got time for this. You want to have a quick look at your watch or a quick connection with the time, don't you? rather than nefters really being that explicit. So, yeah, I do hope that they're able to kind of reissue that Braille watch because that does sound like a really essential kind of leveller, actually. But, you know, like you said, it's not necessarily that we're asking you to have special adaptations. It's that actually we're waiting for society to become more inclusive.
或者如果你在想，你知道，你有点啰嗦了，朋友。我们真的没有时间讨论这个了。你想快速看一眼你的手表或快速连接时间，对吧？而不是真的那么明确。所以，是的，我确实希望他们能够重新发行那种盲文手表，因为那听起来确实是一种非常必要的平衡器。但是，你知道，就像你说的，并不一定是我们要求你有特殊的调整。而是实际上我们在等待社会变得更加包容。
And then people who have got OK vision might then also really use that and benefit from that as well. for example, Audible. I love listening to audio books. So I will usually listen to business books on Audible, whereas when I'm snuggled down in bed trying to get ready to go to sleep, I prefer fiction in my hands. But yeah, like loads of people have learned amazing things or just listen to pleasure for Audible and audiobooks, haven't they? Like, are you much of an audio listener to things? I do love Audible. I have a lot. a lot of books on there that are sort of on my to be listened to list um i've not had a lot of time since starting the course but yeah i i do love audible i i used to read
然后视力正常的人可能也会真正使用并从中受益。例如，Audible。我喜欢听有声读物。所以我通常会在Audible上听商业书籍，而当我蜷缩在床上准备睡觉时，我更喜欢手里的虚构小说。但是的，就像很多人通过Audible和有声读物学到了了不起的东西，或者只是为了娱乐而听，不是吗？你是一个喜欢听音频的人吗？我确实喜欢Audible。我有很多书在上面，都在我的“待听”列表里。自从开始这门课程以来，我没有太多时间，但是的，我确实喜欢Audible。我过去常读
physical books as a teenager very very close to my face um and then i sort of transition to my ipad and i'd have the text really really big and really high contrast and i can still do that but it's very taxing um so audiobooks are just brilliant for that and it is is a nice example of just how universal design and accessibility just works for a lot of people that way. Yeah, it really does. And if it's okay, could you tell us a bit about whether your eyes cause you discomfort? So you said you might get eye strain. Are you having to, you know, apply drops? Are you having to have any time off? Are you having to have shorter days to be mindful of your eyesight? How does the actual physical care of your eyes work? So I used to have a lot of
青少年时期的实体书，离我的脸非常非常近，然后我转到了iPad上，我会把文字调得非常非常大，对比度非常高，我仍然可以这样做，但这非常费力。所以有声读物在这方面非常棒，这是一个很好的例子，说明通用设计和无障碍功能是如何以这种方式造福许多人的。是的，确实如此。如果可以的话，你能告诉我们你的眼睛是否会引起不适吗？所以你说你可能会眼睛疲劳。你是否需要，你知道，滴眼药水？你是否需要请假？你是否需要缩短工作时间来注意你的视力？你眼睛的实际物理护理是如何进行的？所以我过去有很多
pain. And then I had some surgery, which has resolved a lot of that. So I wouldn't necessarily say I deal with a lot of eye pain anymore, which is really great because that was very, very hard at university. During my undergrad, I missed a lot of lectures and had to catch up online and things. But I suppose one of the reasonable adjustments that I have now in work is disability related leave or special leave to attend specifically like my eye hospital recently I had a bit of a eye scare where we weren't sure if I was having a retinal detachment and I had to go to hospital quite a lot in the space of a week and luckily the staff and the course have all been incredibly supportive and understanding but yeah it's just another thing that I have to think
疼痛。然后我做了一些手术，解决了很多问题。所以我不会说我还会处理很多眼痛，这真的很棒，因为在大学时那非常非常困难。在本科期间，我错过了很多讲座，不得不在线补课。但我认为我现在工作中合理的调整之一是与残疾相关的休假或特别休假，专门去参加像我的眼科医院那样的活动。最近我有点眼睛恐慌，我们不确定我是否视网膜脱落，我在一周内不得不去医院很多次，幸运的是，工作人员和课程都非常支持和理解，但是的，这只是我必须考虑的另一件事
about how I structure my days and my weeks and making sure that things like lighting are suitable and that I can navigate a space and that Derek's needs are met and I can get him water and take him outside when I need to. There's just lots of thinking about the practicalities and travelling to and from placement and teaching and yeah, there's a lot to think about. And when you're on a placement day, I presume you have to take, do you take food for Derek or is he a dog that only eats at morning and night? Like, how does that work practically? So he just has breakfast and dinner.
关于我如何安排我的日子和几周，确保照明等条件合适，我可以在空间中导航，德的需求得到满足，我可以在需要时给他水并带他出去。有很多关于实际问题的思考，以及往返实习和教学的交通，是的，有很多需要考虑的事情。当你实习时，我想你必须带食物给德吗？还是他是一只只在早晚吃饭的狗？这在实践中是如何运作的？所以他只吃早餐和晚餐。
And then throughout the day, as I believe most service dogs do, I have a treat pouch on me and he'll get different treats because we're sort of constantly training. But yeah, so luckily I don't really have to think about bringing any food unless I was doing a late shift. say, for example, if I was going to work 12 till 8 instead, then I'd probably bring his dinner and give it to him there. But I do have to think about, you know, setting up a little space for him with his bed and his water bowl and a toy and things like that.
然后整天，我相信大多数服务犬一样，我身上有一个零食袋，他会得到不同的零食，因为我们一直在训练。但是的，所以幸运的是，除非我上晚班，否则我真的不需要考虑带任何食物。例如，如果我改为工作12点到8点，那么我可能会带他的晚餐并在那里给他。但我确实需要考虑，你知道，为他设置一个小空间，放上他的床、水碗、玩具之类的东西。
So one placement, you'd have an extra bed and you'd leave that placement, I guess, rather than kind of having this big rucksack with Derek's things and your things and everything. You have many, many beds for Derek that are Derek approved and he's a fan of. that seems important absolutely um could you tell us before we finish what what is glaucoma in case people aren't aware oh you're going to test me here it's one of those things that i've just sort of grown up being being told about and think about did anyone ever really teach me but um basically it means that i have high pressure in my eyes so the sort of the fluid inside my eyes builds up and doesn't release how it should, which can put pressure on the optic nerve at the
所以一个安置点，你会有额外的床位，我想你会离开那个安置点，而不是带着一个装满德里克的东西、你的东西和所有杂物的大背包。你为德里克准备了许多许多他认可且喜欢的床，这似乎非常重要。嗯，在我们结束之前，你能告诉我们什么是青光眼吗？以防人们不了解。哦，你这是在考我。这是我从小就被告知并思考的事情之一，但我不知道是否有人真正教过我。但嗯，基本上这意味着我的眼压很高，所以眼内的液体积聚，没有按应有的方式排出，这会对视神经造成压力，在
back of the eye, which then causes permanent damage and vision loss. And I know generally it's considered to be something that affects older people later in life, but it can also be inherited or you can be born with it. They're not entirely sure on the causes, but it can also be very aggressive when you're born with it and then it can lead to a lot of secondary eye conditions as well because of all the drops and the surgeries um yeah thank you that seems really important that we have an understanding of what that is but it sounds like you know you've you've had to endure a lot since since you were born and um your parents must have really had to work hard to advocate for you and your needs as a as a as a blind baby um
眼球后部，从而导致永久性损伤和视力丧失。我知道通常人们认为这是一种影响老年人的疾病，但它也可能是遗传的，或者你天生就有。他们并不完全确定原因，但如果你天生就有，它也可能非常具有侵略性，而且由于所有的滴眼液和手术，它也可能导致许多继发性眼部疾病。嗯，是的，谢谢你，了解这一点似乎非常重要。但听起来你从出生起就忍受了很多，而且你的父母一定为了为你争取权益和满足你作为一个盲婴的需求付出了很多努力。
And a blind, I cannot imagine trying to parent my children when they were toddlers if they hadn't had, you know, lots of usable vision. Like it feels dangerous enough with kids with more vision. Like did they, how did they, do you know much about how they did that practically? Yeah. So my mum raised me and my sister and my sister's fully cited. But I know that it was a struggle. I was always in pain. I had to be, I could never lay down because I was in lots of pain.
作为一个盲人，我无法想象当我的孩子还是蹒跚学步的幼儿时，如果他们没有多少可用视力，我该如何抚养他们。这感觉对于视力更好的孩子来说已经够危险了。他们，他们是怎么做到的？你知道他们实际上是怎么做到的吗？是的。所以我妈妈抚养我和我姐姐长大，我姐姐视力完全正常。但我知道那是一场挣扎。我一直很痛苦。我必须，我永远不能躺下，因为我非常痛苦。
And I had to have blankets over the push chair because the sun was too bright. I remember having, even into like sort of middle childhood blankets over lamps and things because things were too bright. As far as my vision, I was a very confident child and I think I could see enough that I could get by. And I'm sure my mom had her worries here and there about me like running down the hill and into something. But generally I think, you know, she encouraged me to just explore the world and climb trees and be as adventurous as I could. She didn't want me to not do things. You know, doctors said to her that I would never ride a bike.
我不得不给婴儿车盖上毯子，因为阳光太刺眼了。我记得即使到了童年中期，我还要在灯具等东西上盖上毯子，因为光线太强了。至于我的视力，我是一个非常自信的孩子，我想我能看到的足够多，足以应付生活。我相信我妈妈偶尔会担心我，比如我跑下山撞到什么东西。但总的来说，我认为她鼓励我探索世界，爬树，尽可能地去冒险。她不想让我因为视力而放弃尝试。你知道，医生曾告诉她我永远不会骑自行车。
And she sort of took that as a challenge. Like, yes, she will ride a bike. So, yeah, I think it was more so the pain and just, you know, she had to pin me down to do eyedrops and things. which I must have been brutal for her to do yeah yeah it I well my heart goes out to her but also to you being a little distress baby not wanting these eyedrops and finding everything so painful like it's it's not been easy for you do you still do sport do you still do exercise are you kind of you know what what are you up to for your for your hobbies um I definitely don't do as much active stuff as I'd like um I've really
她把这当作一种挑战。就像，不，她会骑自行车的。所以，是的，我想更多的是痛苦，你知道，她不得不按住我来滴眼药水之类的。这对她来说一定很残忍。是的，是的，我为她感到难过，也为你感到难过，作为一个痛苦的小婴儿，不想滴眼药水，觉得一切都那么痛苦。这对你来说不容易。你现在还做运动吗？你还锻炼吗？你最近在忙什么爱好？嗯，我做的运动确实没有我想要的那么多。我真的
I've recently been in touch with a local aerial fitness studio trying to see if I can try some of that because that sort of piques my interest, just to get a bit more active and try something new. I love learning new things, so we'll see how that goes. But more generally, I love travelling. My fiancé and I went interrailing for a couple of months around Europe, which is a whole other world of thinking about how you do that when you're disabled. But yeah, I just love going out and exploring and trying new things. Amazing. I'm thinking that Derek would much prefer the trains than the aerial hoops. I'm not sure we're going to be getting Derek on the ribbons any time soon. Thank you so much for your time. Is there anything you think is really important that we share with the audience before we finish Sky? I think just to say how valuable and enriching disabled voices are, not just in clinical psychology, but just broadly, I think you know, society's attitudes are improving, but it's still generally, I think often disabled
我最近联系了一家当地的空中健身工作室，想看看能不能尝试一下，因为这引起了我的兴趣，只是想让自己更活跃一点，尝试一些新事物。我喜欢学习新东西，所以我们看看会怎么样。但更广泛地说，我喜欢旅行。我和我的未婚夫在欧洲进行了几个月的火车旅行，这又是关于残疾人如何旅行的另一个层面的思考。但是的，我只是喜欢出去探索和尝试新事物。太棒了。我想德里克肯定比空中吊环更喜欢火车。我不确定我们很快就能让德里克玩绸缎。非常感谢你的时间。在你结束之前，你认为有什么重要的事情需要和听众分享吗，Sky？我想说的是，残疾人的声音是多么宝贵和丰富，不仅在临床心理学中，而且在更广泛的领域。我认为社会态度正在改善，但总的来说，我认为残疾人
people are overlooked and just disability as a minority is overlooked. You know, it's the only minority group that anybody can join at any point. You know, you're just an illness or an accident away. And I think it's important to be to be mindful of that and how we make the world more accessible and inclusive and value the contributions that disabled people bring because we are, you know, generalising but we're great problem solvers we're incredibly ambitious i think often to our own detriment because we're trying to overcompensate but yeah we have a lot to bring um so yeah but also it's very hard like acknowledging that is important i don't want to make this too in like like it's an inspirational story because it's it's hard it's very hard advocating for yourself all the time
往往被忽视，残疾作为一个少数群体被忽视了。你知道，这是唯一一个任何人随时都可能加入的少数群体。你可能只是一场疾病或一次事故之遥。我认为意识到这一点很重要，我们要如何让世界变得更无障碍、更具包容性，并重视残疾人带来的贡献。因为我们，你知道，虽然在概括，但我们是伟大的问题解决者，我们非常有野心，我认为这往往是以牺牲自己为代价的，因为我们试图过度补偿。但是的，我们有很多贡献。嗯，所以是的，但这也很难。承认这一点很重要，我不想把它变成一个励志故事，因为它很难，一直为自己争取权益非常困难。
and pushing the boundaries all the time but it's it's doable and enjoyable do you enjoy what you do Yes, I love it. I absolutely love it. And, yeah, I mean, based off the fact I did two masters, I loved university and I'm loving the Declan course so far. So yeah. Amazing. Long may that last. And thank you for helping myself, but also our audience, you know, really think about this and, you know, empower people to kind of pursue what is a bit of them really, regardless of kind of what they might have been told about themselves or what they might believe about themselves as being possible or impossible. Thank you again so much for your time and do stay in touch, Sky. Thank you so much for having me. It's been great. Oh, brilliant. Thank you so
并且一直突破界限，但这确实是可行的，也是令人愉快的。你喜欢你所做的事情吗？是的，我喜欢。我绝对喜欢。而且，基于我读了两个硕士学位的事实，我喜欢大学生活，而且到目前为止我也很喜欢Declan课程。所以是的。太棒了。希望这种状态能长久保持。感谢你不仅帮助了我，也帮助了我们的听众，真正思考这个问题，并赋予人们力量去追求真正属于他们的东西，无论他们可能被告知关于自己什么，或者他们可能认为自己什么是可能的或不可能的。再次非常感谢你的时间，保持联系，Sky。非常感谢邀请我。这太棒了。哦，太棒了。谢谢你
much for Sky's time. And to you if you are listening or watching this as someone who is not visually impaired, what I would say is that you likely will make mistakes. You likely will make faux paths, just as I finished my call with Sky, I said, lovely to see you, and then we're hung up. And afterwards, I sort of caught myself just as I was clicking the, oh, my watch is telling me the time. That's not helpful. I, yeah, just as I was clicking the end button, I sort of realized what I'd said. And I think we have to forgive ourselves, but also if that was in a client session, I would likely say, I'm really sorry, at the end of our session last time, I realized I did say lovely to see you because it was but I appreciate that might not be a phrase that feels particularly
这么多时间，Sky。如果你作为一名视力正常的人在收听或观看这个节目，我想说的是，你很可能会犯错。你很可能会犯社交失礼，就像我结束与Sky的通话时，我说，很高兴见到你，然后挂断了。事后，就在我点击的时候，我意识到，哦，我的手表在告诉我时间。那没用。我，是的，就在我点击结束按钮时，我意识到我说了什么。我认为我们必须原谅自己，但如果是在客户会谈中，我可能会说，真的很抱歉，上次会谈结束时，我意识到我说了很高兴见到你，因为确实很高兴，但我意识到这可能不是一个感觉特别
inclusive yeah this is like I don't know the way that I am pleasant with people and it was lovely to see her you know um we can we can second guess ourselves as well but yes that was my own little in process moment um I hope you've found this helpful if you have why not at like subscribe, drop a comment, maybe even drop a question in. If you've got any questions about what it's like to navigate the world as a visually impaired person, we can absolutely get Sky answering some of those. Please do subscribe or follow for more. If you're on Spotify, you can drop any questions in there as well. By the time this episode comes out, there will also be the opportunity for subscriber only content, which will be available for a small
包容的短语。是的，这就像，我不知道，我对待人的方式很友善，见到她确实很高兴。嗯，我们也可以反思自己。但是的，那是我自己的一个小过程时刻。我希望你觉得这有帮助。如果你觉得有帮助，为什么不点赞、订阅、发表评论，甚至提出一个问题呢？如果你对作为一名视障人士在世界上穿行是什么感觉有任何疑问，我们绝对可以让Sky回答其中的一些问题。请务必订阅或关注以获取更多内容。如果你在Spotify上，也可以在那里留下任何问题。当这一集发布时，也将有机会获得仅限订阅者的内容，这些内容将以少量
fee, which is to help me to be able to continue to bring you really high quality, great episodes. And that is going to be available from YouTube and from Spotify and I hope from Apple Podcasts as well. So do check that out. And there's a chance to get some kind of behind the scene staff, some more insightful, kind of reflective pieces from me, thinking about how I begin to plan and put together things. Yeah. And actually, even if you're listening to this as a qualified member of staff or someone that just passionately believe psychologists and people working in psychology are to be invested in, and you might consider subscribing just for that content so that you can help to support my creator cost to keep me being able to do this
费用提供，这将帮助我能够继续为你带来高质量、精彩的剧集。这将在YouTube和Spotify上提供，我也希望在Apple Podcasts上也能提供。所以请务必查看一下。还有机会获得一些幕后花絮，一些更深刻、更具反思性的内容，思考我如何开始计划和整合事物。是的。而且实际上，即使你作为一名合格的工作人员或只是热切相信心理学家和从事心理学工作的人应该得到投资的人在听这个节目，你也可以考虑仅仅为了这些内容而订阅，这样你就可以帮助支持我的创作成本，让我能够继续做这件事
for longer. Thank you so much for anybody who's already doing that by the time this goes live. I would love your feedback as well. In the episode, Sky and I briefly touched on the Snowden Trust and it was the Snowden Trust that offered a scholarship to Sky so she was able to do her second masters. If you are disabled and interested in accessing education, please do do check out their website, which is snowdon trust.org. Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences.
更久。非常感谢所有在这一集上线时已经这样做的人。我也很乐意收到你的反馈。在这一集中，Sky和我简要提到了Snowden信托基金，正是Snowden信托基金为Sky提供了奖学金，使她能够完成第二个硕士学位。如果你是残疾人并有兴趣接受教育，请务必查看他们的网站，即snowdontrust.org。嗨，我叫Beth，是来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。我只想对《临床心理学家集体》一书的撰稿人表示最大的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很喜欢深入了解各种背景和经历。
People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的经历，了解申请的潜在障碍以及我如何尝试解决这些问题也非常有趣。我真的开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士学位，但这确实给了我所需要的信心去尝试一下。所以，最大的感谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。